The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN LEONARD: OK, thanks.
Thanks for the
opportunity to talk.
So hi, everyone.
It's a great pleasure
to talk here at MBL.
I've been coming to the
Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institution for many years as
my first thing over here at MBL.
And so I'm going to try to cover
three different topics, which
is probably a little
ambitious on time.
But there's so much
I'd love to say to you.
I want to talk about
self-driving cars.
And use it as a context
to think about questions
of representation for
localization and mapping,
and maybe connect it into
some of the brain questions
that you folks
are interested in,
and time permitting,
at the end mention
a little bit of work we've
done on object-based mapping
in my lab.
So my background-- I
grew up in Philadelphia.
Went to UPenn for engineering.
But then went to Oxford to do
my PhD at a very exciting time
when their computer vision
and robotics group was just
being formed at Oxford
under Michael Brady.
And then I came back to
MIT and started working
with underwater vehicles.
And that's when I got involved
with Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institution.
And I was very fortunate
to join the AI lab back
around 2002, which
became part of CSAIL.
And really, I've
been able to work
with really amazing
colleagues and amazing robots
in a challenging
set of environments.
So autonomous
underwater vehicles
provide a very unique challenge
because we have very poor
communications to them.
Typically, we use
acoustic modems
that might give you 96 bytes if
you're lucky every 10 seconds
to a few kilometers range.
And so we also need to think
about the sort of constraints
of running in real
time onboard a vehicle.
And so the sort of work
that my lab's done--
the more we investigate
more fundamental questions
about robot perception,
navigation, and mapping,
we also are involved
in building systems.
So this is a project I did for
the Office of Naval Research
some years ago using
small vehicles that
would reacquire
mine-like targets
on the bottom for the Navy.
And so this is an example
of a more applied system
where we had a very small
resource-constrained platform.
And the sort of work we
did is a robot built a map
as it performed its
mission, and then matched
the map against
the prior map to do
terminal guidance to a target.
Another big system
I was involved with,
as Russ mentioned, was
the Urban Challenge.
And I'll say a bit about
that in the context
of self-driving cars.
So let's see.
So who's heard any of the
recent statements from Elon Musk
from Tesla?
So he said self-driving
cars are solved- he said.
And a particular thing that
he said that just made my--
I don't know, maybe steam
came out of my head--
was that he compared
autonomous cars
with elevators that used
to require operators
but are now self-service.
So imagine you getting in
a car, pressing a button,
and arriving at MIT in
Cambridge 80 miles away,
navigating through
the Boston downtown
highways and intersections.
And maybe that will happen.
But I think it's going to
take a lot longer than folks
are saying.
And some of that comes from
just fundamental questions
and intelligence and robotics.
So in a nutshell, when Musk
says that self-driving is solved
I think he's wrong, as
much as I admire what
Tesla and SpaceX have done.
And so to talk
about that, I think
we need to be very honest as
a field about our failures
as well as our
successes, and try
to balance what you hear in the
media with the reality of where
I think we are.
And so I wanted
to quote verbatim
what Russ said about
the robotics challenge,
about a project that was
so exhausting and just
all-consuming and so
stressful, yet so rewarding.
So we did this in
2006 and 2007--
my wonderful colleagues,
Seth Teller, John Howe,
Amelia Fratoli--
amazing students and postdocs.
We had a very large team.
And we tried to push
the limit on what
was possible with perception
and real-time motion planning.
So our vehicle built a
local map as it traveled
from its perceptual data,
using data from laser scanners
and cameras.
And we didn't want to
blindly follow GPS.
We wanted the car to
make its own decisions
because GPS navigation was
part of the original quest
with the challenge.
And so Seth Teller and
his student, Albert Wang,
developed a vision-based
perceptual system
where the car tried to detect
from curbs and lane markings
in very challenging
vision conditions.
For example, looking
into the sun, which
you'll see in a second--
really challenging situation for
trying to perceive the world.
And so our vehicle--
at the time, we went a little
crazy on the computation.
We had 10 blades,
each with four cores--
40 cores-- which may not seem
a lot now, but we needed 3.5
kilowatts just to power
the computer at full tilt.
We fully loaded the computer
with a randomized motion
planner, with all these
perception algorithms.
We had a Velodyne laser
scanner on the roof.
And about 12 other laser
scanners, 5 cameras, 15 radars,
and we really pushed the
envelope on algorithms.
And so when faced with a
choice in a DARPA challenge,
if you want to win
at all costs you
might simplify, or try to
read the rules carefully,
or guess the rule
simplifications.
But that would have
meant just sort
of turning off the work
of our PhD students,
and we didn't want to do that.
So at the end of the day,
all credit to the teams
that did well.
Carnegie Mellon--
first, $2 million,
Stanford-- second, $1 million,
Virginia Tech-- third,
half a million
dollars, MIT-- fourth,
and nothing for fourth place.
But it was quite an
amazing experience.
And in the spirit of
advertising our failures
I think I have
time to show this.
This used to be painful
for me to watch.
But now I've gotten over it.
This is our--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Let's check in once
again with the boss.
JOHN LEONARD: Even though
we finished the race,
we had a few incidents so
DARPA stopped things and let
us continue.
- --across the line.
JOHN LEONARD: Carnegie-Mellon,
who won the race.
Why did that stop?
Let's see.
- --at the end of mission
two behind Virginia Tech.
Virginia Tech got
a little issue.
[INAUDIBLE] Here's--
JOHN LEONARD: We were trying to
pass Cornell for a few minutes.
- Looks like they're stopped.
And it looks like they're--
that the 79 is trying
to pass and has
passed the chase vehicle
for Skynet, the 26 vehicle.
Wow.
And now he's done it.
And Talos is going to pass.
Very aggressive.
And, whoa.
Ohh.
We had our first collision.
Crash in turn one.
Oh boy.
That is, you know,
that's a bold maneuver.
[END PLAYBACK]
JOHN LEONARD: So what
actually happened?
So it turned out
Cornell were having
problems with their actuators.
They were sort of stopping
and starting and stopping
and starting.
And we had some problems.
It turned out we
had about five bugs.
They had about five
bugs that interacted.
And here's a computer's eye--
sort of, brain of
the robot's view.
Now back in '07, we weren't
using a lot of vision
for object detection
and classification.
So with the laser scanner--
the Cornell vehicle's there.
It has a license plate.
It has tail lights.
It has a big number 26.
It's on the middle of a road.
We should know that's a car.
Stay away from it.
But to the laser
scanner it's just
a blob of laser scanner data.
And even when we pull
around the side of the car
we weren't clever enough
with our algorithms
to fill in the fact
that it's a car.
And you have the problem
when it starts moving
of the aperture problem--
that as you're moving,
and it's moving,
it's very hard to tell and
deduce the true motion.
Now, another thing that
happened was we had a threshold.
And so in our
150,000 lines of code
our wonderfully
gifted student, who's
now a tenured professor
at Michigan, Ed Olson,
had a threshold of
3 meters per second.
So anything moving faster
than 3 meters per second
could be a car.
Anything less than 3 meters
per second couldn't be a car.
Now that might
seem kind of silly.
But it turns out that
slowly moving obstacles
are much harder to
detect and classify
than fast moving obstacles.
That's one reason that
city driving or driving,
say, in a shopping mall parking
lot is actually in many ways
more challenging than
driving on the highway.
And so despite our best efforts
to stop at the last minute,
we steered into the car and
had this little minor fender
bender.
But one thing that we did
is we made all our data
available open source.
And we actually wrote
a journal article
on this incident
and a few others.
And so if you'd asked
me then in 2007,
I would have said we're
a long way from turning
your car loose on
the streets of Boston
with absolutely no user input.
And the real challenge is our
uncertainty and robustness
and developing robust
systems that really work.
But for our system, some of the
algorithm progress we made--
I mentioned the lane tracking.
Albert Wang, who's now, I think,
working at Google, developed--
was given very sparse--
I'd say about 10% of
the recent graduates
or more are working
at Google these days.
AUDIENCE: Albert's
at [INAUDIBLE]..
JOHN LEONARD: Oh.
OK.
And then here is a video
for the qualifying event
to get into the final race.
We had to navigate-- whoops,
I can't press the mouse.
That's going to stop.
So we had to navigate
along a curved road
with very sparse waypoints.
And so, in real
time the computer
has to make decisions
about what it sees.
Where is the road?
Where am I?
Are there obstacles?
And there are no parked
cars in this situation,
but other stretches
had parked cars.
And our car-- in a nutshell,
if our robot became
confused about where the
road was it would stop.
It would have to wait
and get its courage up,
like lowering its
thresholds as it was stuck.
But we were the only
team to our knowledge
to qualify without
actually adding waypoints.
So it turns out the
other top teams,
they just went in with
a Google satellite image
and just added a breadcrumb
trail for the robot to follow,
simplifying the perception.
So this was back in '07.
Now let's fast forward to 2015.
And right now-- so
of course, we have
the Google self-driving
car which has just
been an amazing project.
And you've all probably
seen these videos,
each with millions
of hits on YouTube.
The earlier one of taking
a blind person for a ride
to Taco Bell, this was
driving-- that was 2012, city
streets in 2014, spring 2015.
And then the new
Google car, which
won't have a steering wheel
in its final instantiation,
won't have pedals.
It will just have a stop button.
And that's your analogy
to the elevator.
And so I think that the Google
car is an amazing research
project that might one
day transform mobility.
But I do think,
with all sincerity--
so I rode in the
Google car last summer.
I was blown away.
I felt like I was on
the beach at Kitty Hawk.
It's like this just
really profound technology
that could in the long term
have a very big impact.
And I have amazing
respect for that team--
Chris Urmson, Mike
Montemerlo, et cetera.
But I think in the media and
in others, the technology
has been a bit overhyped, and
it's poorly misunderstood.
And a lot of it goes down to
how the car localizes itself,
how it uses prior
maps, and how they
simplify the task of driving.
And so even though
people like Musk
have said driving
is a solved problem,
I think we have to be
aware that just because it
works for Google, doesn't mean
it'll work for everybody else.
So critical differences between
Google and, say, everyone else.
And this is with all
respect to all players.
I'm not trying to criticize.
It's more just trying
to balance the debate.
The Google car
localizes on the left
with a prior map, where they
map the lighter intensity off
of the ground surface.
And they will annotate
the map by hand--
adding pedestrian crossings,
adding stoplights.
They'll drive a car
around many, many times,
and then do a SLAM process
to optimize the map.
But if the world
changes, they're
going to have to adapt to that.
Now, they've shown the ability
to do response to construction,
bicyclists with hand signals.
When I was in the car we
crossed the railroad tracks.
That just blew me away.
I mean, it's pretty
impressive capability but more
a vision-based approach that
just follows the lane markings.
If the lane markings are
good, everything's fine.
In fact, Tesla either
just have released--
or are about to release--
their autopilot software, which
is an advanced lane
keeping system.
And Elon Musk, a few weeks
ago, posted on Twitter
that there's one last
corner case for us to fix.
And apparently he-- on part of
his commute in the Los Angeles
area there is well
defined lane markings.
And part of it is a concrete
road with weeds and skid marks
and so forth.
And he said publicly that the
system works well if the lane
markings are well-defined.
But for more challenging
vision conditions
like looking into the sun
it doesn't work as well.
And so the critical
difference is
if you're going to use
the LiDAR with prior maps,
you can do very precise
localization down
to less than 10
centimeters accuracy.
And the way I think about
it is robot navigation
is about three things--
where do you want
the robot to be?
Where does the
robot think it is?
And where really is the robot?
And when the robot
thinks it's somewhere,
but it's really somewhere
different, that's really bad.
That happens.
We've lost underwater vehicles
and had very nervous searches
to find them--
luckily-- when the
robot made a mistake.
And so with the Google
approach they really
nail this "where am I" problem--
the localization problem.
But it means having
an expensive LiDar.
It means having accurate maps.
It means maintaining them.
One critical distinction
is between level four
and level three.
These are definitions
of autonomy
from the US
government-- from NTSA.
A level four car
is what Google are
trying to do now,
which is really,
you just-- you
could go to sleep.
The car has a 100% control.
You couldn't intervene
if you wanted to.
You just press a button.
Go to sleep.
Wake up at your destination.
Musk has said that he
thinks within five years
you can go to sleep in your
car, which to me I just--
five decades would
impress me, to be honest.
But level three is when the car
is going to do most of the job,
but you have to take over
if something goes wrong.
And for example Delphi drove
99% of the way across the US
in spring of this year,
which is pretty impressive.
But 50 miles had to
be driven by people--
getting on and off of
highways and city streets.
And so there's something
about human nature,
and the way humans interact
with autonomous systems,
that it's actually kind of hard
for a person to pay attention.
Imagine if 99% of the time
the car does it perfectly.
But 1% of the time it's
about to make a mistake,
and you have to be
alert to take over.
And research experience
from aviation
has shown that humans
are actually bad at that.
And another issue
is-- and this is--
I mean, Mountainview is pretty
complicated-- lots of cyclists,
pedestrians, I mentioned
the railroad crossings,
construction.
But in California they've
had this historic drought.
And most of the testing has been
done with no rain, for example,
and no snow.
And if you think about
Boston and Boston roads,
there are some pretty
challenging situations.
And so for myself, when I
first-- a couple of years ago
I said I didn't expect
a taxi in Manhattan
in my lifetime-- a
fully autonomous taxi--
to go anywhere in Manhattan.
And I got criticized
online for saying that.
So I put a dash cam on
my car, and actually
had my son record
cell phone footage.
The upper left is
making a left turn
near my house in Newton, Mass.
And if you look to
the right, there's
cars as far as the eye can see.
And if you look to
the left, there's
cars coming at pretty high
rate of speed, with a mailbox,
and a tree.
And this is a really challenging
behavior for a human,
because it requires making
a decision in real time.
We want very high reliability
in terms of detecting
the cars coming from the left.
But the way that I
pulled out is to wave
at a person in another car.
And those sort of
nods and waves--
they're some of the
most challenging forms
of human-computer interaction.
So imagine vision
algorithms that
could detect a person nodding
at you from the other direction.
Or here's another situation.
This is going through
Coolidge Corner in Brookline.
And I'll show a longer
version of this in a second.
But the light's green.
And see here-- this
police officer?
So despite the green light,
the police officer just
raises their hand, and that
means the signal to stop.
And so interacting with
crossing guards and people--
very challenging,
as well as changes
to the road surface and,
of course, adverse weather.
And so here's a longer sequence
for that police officer.
First of all, you'll see
flashing lights on the left--
which may be flashing
lights, you should pull over.
Here you should just
drive past them.
It's just the cop
left his lights
on when he parked his car.
But the light's red.
And this police
officer is waving me
through a red
light, which I think
is a really advanced behavior.
So imagine a car that's--
imagine the logic for
OK, stop at red lights
unless there's a police
officer waving you through it,
and how you get that reliable.
And now we're going to pull
up to the next intersection,
and this police officer is
going to stop at a green light.
And so despite all the
recent progress in vision,
things like image
labeling, ImageNet--
most of those systems are
trained with vast archives
of images from the internet
where there's no context.
And they're so challenging
for even humans to classify.
So that if you had
some data sets,
like the Caltech
pedestrian data set,
if you got 78% performance,
that's really good.
But we need 99.9999%
or better performance
before we're going
to turn cars loose
in the wild in these
challenging situations.
Now going back more to
localization and mapping.
Here I collected
data for about three
or four weeks of my commuting.
This is crossing the Mass.
Ave. Bridge going from
Boston into Cambridge.
And the lighting
is a little tricky.
But tell me what's
different between the top
and the bottom video.
And notice, by the way, how
close we come to this truck.
The slightest angular error
in your position estimate,
really bad things could happen.
But the top-- this
is a long weekend.
This is Veterans Day weekend.
They repaved the Mass.
Ave. Bridge.
So on the bottom, the
lane lines are gone.
And so if you had an
appearance-based localization
algorithm like
Google's, you would
need to remap the bridge
before you drove on it.
But the lines aren't there yet.
And how well is
it going to work?
And so, this is just a
really tricky situation.
And, of course, there's weather.
Now, snow is
difficult for things
like traction and control.
But for perception, if you look
at how the Google car actually
works--
if you're going to
localize yourself
based on precisely knowing
the car's position down
to centimeters so that you can
predict what you should see,
then if you can't
see the road surface
you're not going to
be able to localize.
And so this is just a
reminder of the sorts of maps
that Google uses.
So I think to make it to really
challenging weather and very
complex environments, we need
a higher level understanding
of the world.
I think more a semantic or
object-based understanding
of the world.
And then, of course, there's
difficulties in perception.
And so what do you
see in this picture?
The sun?
There's a green light there.
I realize the lighting
is really harsh,
and maybe you could do
polarization or something
better.
But does anyone see the
traffic cop standing there?
You can just make out his legs.
There's a policeman there
who gave me this little wave,
even though I was sort
of blinded by the sun.
And he walked out and
put his back to me
and was waving
pedestrians across,
even though the light was green.
So a purely
vision-based system is
going to just need dramatic
leaps in visual performance.
So to wrap up the
self-driving car part,
I think the big questions going
forward-- technical challenges,
maintaining the maps,
dealing with adverse weather,
interacting with people--
both inside and
outside of the car--
and then getting truly robust
computer vision algorithms.
We want to get in a totally
different place on the ROC
curves, or the
precision recall curves,
where approaching perfect
detection with no false alarms.
And that's a really
hard thing to do.
So I've worked my whole
life on the robot mapping
and localization problem.
And for this audience
I wanted to just
ask you a little question.
Does anyone know what the
2014 Nobel Prize in medicine
or physiology was for?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Grid cells.
JOHN LEONARD: Grid cells.
Grid cells and place cells.
And so this has been
called SLAM in the brain.
Now, you might argue.
And we might be very
far from knowing.
But I think it's just
really exciting to--
so for myself, I'll explain.
I've had what's called
an ONR MURI grant--
multidisciplinary university
research initiative grant--
with Mike Hasselmo
and his colleagues
at Boston University.
And these are a couple
of Mike's videos.
And so, I think Matt
Wilson spoke to your group.
And the notion that in
the entorhinal cortex
that there is this sort
of position information
that's very metrical,
and it seems
to be at the heart
of memory formation,
to me is very powerful
and very important.
And so, we have this underlying
question of representation.
How do we represent the world?
And I believe location
is just absolutely
vital to building
memories and to developing
advanced reasoning in the world.
And the fact that
grid cells exist--
to me-- and they have this
role in memory formation
is just this really
exciting concept.
And so, in robotics
we call the problem
of how a robot builds a map
and uses that map to navigate,
SLAM-- simultaneous
localization and mapping.
This is for a PR2 robot being
driven around the second floor
of our building, not far
from Patrick's office
if you recognize any of that.
And this is using stereo vision.
My PhD student,
Hordur Johannsson,
who graduated a
couple of years ago,
created a system to
do real time SLAM
and try to address
how to get temporally
scalable representations.
And one thing you'll see
as the robot goes around
occasionally is
loop closing, where
the robot might come back
and have like, an error
and then correct that error.
So this is the part of the
SLAM problem that in some ways
is well understood
in robotics, which
is how you detect features from
images, track them over time,
and try to bootstrap up,
building a representation
and using that to
locate your estimation.
And I've worked on
this my whole career.
And as a grad student at Oxford,
I had very primitive sensors.
So for a historical SLAM talk I
recently digitized an old video
and some old pictures.
This was in the basement of the
engineering building at Oxford.
This is just the localization
part of how you have a map,
and you generate
predictions-- in this case
for sonar measurements.
And at the time there we had--
I'm sitting at a
SUN workstation.
To my left is something
called a data cube,
which for about $100,000
could just barely
do like real time frame grabbing
and then edge detection out.
And so vision just wasn't ready.
And the exciting
thing now in our field
is vision is ready--
that we're really using
vision in a substantial way.
But I think a lot
about prediction.
If you know your
position, you can
predict what you should see
and create a feedback loop.
And that's sort of what
we're trying to do.
And so SLAM is a
wonderful problem,
I believe, for addressing a
whole great set of questions,
because there are these
different axes of difficulty
that interact with one another.
And one is representation.
How do we represent the world?
And I think that
question-- we still have
a ton of things to think about.
Another is inference.
We want to do real
time inference
about what's where in the
world and how we combine it
all together.
And finally, there's a systems
in autonomy access, where
we want to build systems,
and deploy them, and have
them operate robustly and
reliably in the world.
So in SLAM, here's an
example of how we pose
this as an inference problem.
This is from the classic
Victoria Park data
set from Sydney University.
A robot drives around, in this
case, a park with some trees.
There are landmarks
shown in green.
The robot's positioner
drifts over time.
We have dead reckoning error.
That's shown in blue.
And we estimate the trajectory
of the robot in red,
and the position
of the landmarks
from relative measurement.
So as you take
relative measurements,
and you move through
the world, how
do you put that all together?
And so we, cast this
as an inference problem
where we have the robot
poses, the odometric inputs,
landmarks-- you can do it
with or without landmarks--
and measurements.
And an interesting thing-- so
we have this inference problem
on a belief network.
The key thing about SLAM is
it's building up over time.
So you start with nothing
and the problem's growing
ever larger.
And, let's see,
if I had to say--
25 years of thinking about
this up through 2012,
the most important
thing I learned
is that maintaining sparsity in
the underlying representation
is critical.
And, in fact, for
biological systems
I wonder if there is
evidence of sparsity.
Because sparsity is the
key to doing efficient
inference when you
pose this problem.
And so many algorithms
have basically
boiled down to maintaining
sparsity and the underlying
representations.
So just briefly, the
most important thing I
learned since then in
the last few years--
I'm really excited by building
dense representations.
So this is work in collaboration
with some folks in Ireland--
Tom Whelan, John McDonald--
building on KinectFusion from
Richard Newcombe
and Andrew Davison--
how you can use a GPU to build
a volumetric representation,
and build rich, dense models,
and estimate your motion as you
go through the world.
So this is something we
call continuous or spatially
extended KinectFusion.
This little video here
from three years ago
is going on in an
apartment in Ireland.
And I'll show you
the end result.
Just hand-carrying a
sensor through the world--
and you can see the quality
of the reconstructions
you can build, say,
in the bathroom,
the sink, the tub, the stairs,
to have really rich 3D models
that we can build and then
enable the more advanced
interactions that Russ showed.
That's fantastic.
And I mentioned loop closing--
something we did
a couple of years
ago was adding loop closing to
these dense representations.
So this is-- again, in
CSAIL-- this is walking around
the Stata Center with
about eight minutes of data
going up and down stairs.
If you watch the two blue chairs
near Randy Davis's office,
you can see how they
get locked into place
as you correct the error.
So this is taking mesh
deformation techniques
from graphics and combining it.
So the underlying pose
graph representation
is like a foundation or
a skeleton on which you
build the rich representation.
OK.
So this is the
end resulting map.
And there's been some really
exciting work just this year
from Whelan and from Newcombe
in this space of doing
deformable objects, and
then really scalable
algorithms where you can
sort of paint the world.
So the final thing
I want to talk about
in my last few minutes
is our latest work
of using object-based
representations.
And for this audience,
I think if you go back
to David Marr, who I
feel is unappreciated
in the historical
sense of how I feel,
that vision is the
process of discovering
from images what is present
in the world and where it is.
And to me, the what
and where are coupled.
And maybe that's
been lost a bit.
And I think that's one
way in which robotics
can help, I think, with
vision and brain sciences.
I think we need to develop
object-based understanding
of the world.
So instead of just having
representations that
are a massive amount of
points or purely appearance,
where we can start
to build higher level
and symbolic understanding
of the world.
And so I want to build
rich representations
that leverage knowledge
of your location
to better understand where
objects are and knowledge
about objects to better
understand your location.
And just as a step in that
direction, my student, Sudeep
Pallai, who was one
of Seth's students,
has an RSS paper where we
looked at coupling using SLAM
to get better object recognition
by effectively-- so here's
an example of an input data
stream from Peter Fox's group.
There's just some
objects on the table.
I realize it's a relatively
uncluttered scene.
But this has been a benchmark
for RGBD perception.
And so, if you
combine data as you
move from the world
using a SLAM system to do
3D reconstruction on the
scene, and then using
the reconstructed points to
help improve the prediction
process for object
recognition, it
leads to a more scalable
system for recognizing objects.
And it comes back
to this notion to me
that a big part of perception
is prediction-- the ability
to predict what you see
from a given location.
And so what we're doing
is we're leveraging off
techniques and object detection,
featuring coding and the newer
SLAM algorithms,
and particularly
the semi-dense orb SLAM
technique from Zaragoza, Spain.
And so I'm just going
to jump to the end here.
The key concept is
that by combining
SLAM with object detection we
get much better performance
and object recognition.
So on the left shows our system.
On the right is a classical
approach just looking
at individual frames.
And you can see,
for example, here,
the red cup that's
been misclassified
would get substantially better
performance by using location
to cue the object
detection techniques.
All right.
So I'm going to wrap up.
And just a little bit of
biological inspiration
from our BU
collaborators, Eichenbaum
has looked at the what
and the where pathways
in the entorhinal cortex.
And there's this duality between
location-based and object-based
representations in the brain.
And I think that's
very important.
OK.
So my dream is persistent
autonomy and lifelong map
learning and making
things robust.
And just for this
group I made a--
I just want to
pose some questions
on the biological side,
and I'll stop here.
So some questions-- do
biological representations
support multiple
location hypotheses?
Even though we think
we know where we are,
robots are faced with multimodal
situations all the time.
And I wonder if
there is any evidence
for multiple hypotheses in
the underlying representations
in the brain, even if they don't
rise to the conscious level,
and how experiences
build over time.
And the question-- what are
the grid cells really doing?
Are they a form of
path integration?
Or there obviously, to me,
seems to be some correction.
And my crazy hypothesis as
a non-brain brain scientist
is, do grid cells serve as
an indexing mechanism that
effectively facilitates search--
so a location index search
so that you can have
these pointers to what
and where information
get coupled together.